nous sommes une agence internationale et
indépendante de renseignement opérant un
très haut niveau de discrétion ça
c'était la une du journal le lendemain
du jour où j'ai désamorcer une bombe à
berlin à la une des journaux en toutes
ces occasions il n'y avait que des
idiots si c'est la nature de kingman que
nos réussites reste secrète
jusqu'au quai vallet soft machine assez
profond elle craint kingman n'a rien à
voir avec les origines de sa naissance
ti cul prêt à t'adapter à apprendre tu
peut tout changer
ça c'est dingue yes j'en est excellent
fédérer c'est de toute façon j'ai plus
grand chose à perdre
où il ya beaucoup à perdre sachez vous
le garantis ballantine est une menace
qui nous affecte tous un génocide de
masse et sa j'adore
c'est complètement simple lien sans
jamais rien à assembler les kings
semaine
c'est un peu too much non compte à
rebours enclenché
c'est parti
seigneur
franchement en havrais j'avais besoin de
me défouler
s'ils trouvent le monde comme
embrasserait jeu tandja plus qu'un
simple petit jeu revient bougez pas
le fils de [ __ ]